[Music]
all right it's just don't want to miss a
thing it's a single aerosmith song and
this guy's letting his entire letting it
kill him it's like dude aerosmith also
made the song pink and dream on like
dude come on it's one scene jesus christ
crazy where he talks about his you know
budgeting dog
i don't blame her because i would get
tired of his [ __ ] too
no that's i'm not blaming her i'm i'm
saying the point that this guy's letting
this [ __ ] him up so much you know what i
mean
uh
let's see
okay
um
you know what i was thinking what
[Music]
i i really don't think that the animal
cracker qualifies as a cracker why well
because it's sweet which to me suggests
cookie and you know
maybe putting cheese on something sort
of the defining characteristic of what
makes a cracker wow this is a great
movie huh guys
are you listening to the wonderful
michael bay biology
what is this are you saying only the
kevin smith dialogue right this is no no
no aaron sorkin ain't got nothing on
michael bay's dialogue did you see that
go i think a cracker she got cheese on
it i'm from boston ah that's wicked
wicked awesome but crackers should have
cheese bro what the [ __ ] this entire sex
scene about a [ __ ] animal cracker
with [ __ ] arrow smith playing this is
so bad
who wrote this
you know what they call you know what
they call an animal cracker in france
crackling and a mouth
what a [ __ ] movie
well because it's sweet which to me
suggests cookie and you know
maybe putting cheese on something sort
of defining character you know the thing
is we need better music for the scene
there it
[Music]
phillip though i is like a little animal
cracker discovery chicken
watch the gazelle as he grazes through
the open plank
look i don't like big government you
know i don't like i don't want any more
government i hate government but i think
we should pass a law
to make it that we could never have a
sex scene start with animal crackers
again i think everyone would be on board
right i think nobody would fight that
or
or
or
hear me out oh
all sex scenes involve animal crackers
god damn it you're normalizing it that's
what you're doing you're normalizing it
you shifty jew he's trying to normalize
animal crackers and sex scenes
hey i don't see anything wrong with a
little you know like a little crumbly
lion or half a panda in the bedroom i
don't see half a panda
elephant milkies
ever eat animal crackers the gorilla had
the milkies right fair enough
when did armageddon come out what year
um 99
was it before 9 11
no 98
98 98 98 armageddon so just to show you
guys that's how topical day wave is some
of you weren't even born one thing we're
talking about came out see what you're
seeing there's uh liv tyler
uh she is the daughter of the singer of
the song who was born in 98 or 99 i'm
really curious to see how many people
have no clue no miami milf not
in 98.
we're talking yeah the other way okay
whoever hasn't seen this scene get ready
because he just crams those crackers in
her ass dude he gets a handful of them
and he smushes them in her [ __ ] he just
getting mushes him
and she has a hand up here baby because
i'll cram those crackers into you
he grows um crushes them in his hand and
goes
bubbles
let's play barnum and bailey your
pussy's a circus tent and we're gonna
let the animals in
oh god what a stupid scene
oh [ __ ]
98 oh some people were born in 98
96 rep some of you were two some of you
were babies
i was eight when this came out
uh
i was 16.
yeah i was uh
sixth in high school
somebody said sopping bush with cracker
dust sounds amazing
yeah the gazelle is a little spooked
whoa the gazelle do you know what color
he
is head north
to the oh my god is he doing fine
probably still the guy by the way can i
point something out sorry because he
would interrupt you but he's
he is he's really leaning into this
animal [ __ ] [ __ ] metaphor he's
doing a nature dog voice dude what the
[ __ ]
so we're definitely watching this here
we see two gazelles around the watering
hole oh [ __ ] what a bad movie this was
rice i think you're selling pessi on
this i'm just gonna shove all these
animal crackers in your [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold on up to you one second hey buy
animal crackers quick
animal animal crackers babe and cheese
whip okay
no no no you don't put cheese on animal
crackers have you not been following
royce i wasn't paying attention
[Laughter]
this is so stupid
why was this film scene why was the
scene filmed what was the point of this
man
dude he talks about
the [ __ ] he talks about the animal
crackers for way too long
like how long is this scene by the way
it did two minutes and eight seconds for
[ __ ] dude lift tyler sitting there
with her [ __ ] tits out and you
instead of [ __ ] finger blasting her
you keep talking about it what are you
autistic what are you doing
by the way
not to forget and i want to remind
everybody steven tyler her dad is
[ __ ] the soundtrack of this animal
cracker [ __ ] fast
he's doing the animal cracker [ __ ] right
he's like oh and here we see the lion
and she goes oh is that a snake and she
reaches for a stick and he swats her
hand away and he goes no
so anyway the lion and the gorilla
play with animal crackers on don't write
it down
make noises like
don't make don't make the noises don't
make them
stop it
do you want answering your [ __ ] because
that's how you get ants in your [ __ ]
oh then proceed
chokes you up these crackers [ __ ] all
along
shove it up sopping
bush
they're gonna have to call [ __ ]
exterminators at the end of the movie to
get all the ants out of her [ __ ]
peter approaches watch
exactly this is too long
it was a little spooked
then you could head north
to the ample
um sorry about that guys
a little research a little restream
server part
uh i'm sorry what were we doing oh
that's right for those who might have
missed it because the stream went down
for a second we're watching hour four of
ben affleck playing playing [ __ ]
safari on lift tyler's chest instead of
[ __ ] her like any person male or
female by the way would do in this
position
right
yes like i know girls that aren't even
in any way into chicks that would go
yeah but i would have to [ __ ] with tyler
right like i mean come on tyler
madness see what she looks like now
she's still looking good
now here's the thing
if ben affleck makes out with liv tyler
that is he literally has
stephen tyler's grown-up [ __ ] in his
mouth
a side-by-side comparison
with father and daughter
yeah she still looks this is her now
right she still looks fantastic like she
still looks great yep i mean
dude
she looks great
big feet didn't everybody that's how big
her feet were
uh
um
you're like the first foot guy can i
gazelle now faces man's most perilous
question
so are you gonna have sex with me or
like i'm not even that hungry
so
way
down
dude imagine
having lyft tyler being half naked
and
not immediately throwing the [ __ ]
animal crackers as far as you could and
immediately having sex with her
wait a minute i think this is locking
the long term book or booking oh this is
long-term booking okay yeah
do not put the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i forgot about that he actually because
you were joking i i did actually forget
that he shoves one of them in her
[ __ ] underwear
and she likes it remember the scene okay
remember the scene in hot shots where
they're making fun of sex scenes and he
starts cooking on her stomach oh when he
cracks the egg on her belly that is what
this feels like right
yes
tune in next week
all right let's go to bed wait you're
not gonna [ __ ] me now i'm
tired and there's these no i'm full but
you just ate one animal cracker
babe okay hold on hold on
back up here for a second
okay
baby
can you please get the animal crackers
out of my underwear
is your animal cracker no leave them
there till they're soft
like cereal
do you think it's possible that anyone
else in the world is
doing this very same thing at this point
i can emphatically say no
nobody else in the world right now
is [ __ ]
having a guy with a huge face
play with animal crackers near or around
their [ __ ] you're the only one i
promise you
my wife would slap me are you [ __ ]
joking what the [ __ ] man
i'm just doing my job over here
i hope so
otherwise what the hell are we trying to
say
oh jj thank you you're welcome jj thank
you
that's i'm sorry it's only one boob but
yeah oh yay now that other one that's
legit her
yeah you want more
oh she really does she does have a
sopping bush yes she does
[Music]
for those who don't know we're looking
at her boob and uh her [ __ ] here
because you have to like you have to
wade through a mountain of fakes but
they're every once in a while there's a
real one
honk don't honk it
[Music]
come on let's get in my bmw z
cut our mustaches
bruce willis i wouldn't trust him bruce
willis sacrifices himself
at the end of the movie so she could be
so she could go play animal crackers
with ben affleck the rest of her life